عندما تكون هناك إدارة جديدة ، فكم
ستكون عدوانيًا في الضغط على أنهم يمتلكون
الاختبار ، استخدم قانون الإنتاج الدفاعي ،
ابدأ في تكثيف الكواشف التي
نحتاجها لهذا الاختبار المنزلي المعتمد من إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
لأنه حتى لو كان بإمكانك تحمل 50
دولارًا للجهاز وأيًا كان  ستكلف
الكواشف والمواد الكيميائية الأخرى
ولن يتمكن الكثير من الأشخاص
من القيام بذلك ما لم يتم تمويلها من قبل
الحكومة الفيدرالية ،
سنواجه نقصًا في
جانب التصنيع ، فأنت بحاجة إلى مزيد من الاختبارات
لأنواع مختلفة من الاختبارات
أه وأنت تعلم  كم ستكون عدوانيًا
في جعل هذه الأولوية
بعد ما تعلمته على مدار
الأشهر الماضية
جيدًا ، لقد كنت لفترة طويلة الآن
أدفع فكرة أنك بحاجة
إلى اختبار الأشخاص الموجودين في
المجموعة غير المصحوبة بأعراض
لك  أحتاج إلى استخدام الكلمة التي كانت
قبل شهور كريس
لإغراق النظام بالاختبار حتى
تتمكن من
الشعور بتغلغل هذا الانتشار المجتمعي
الذي هو انتشار بدون أعراض لقد كنت
في تلك الذرة  r
لفترة طويلة ولن
أتغير ولكن ما مدى الاختلاف الكبير الذي
سيحدثه إذا بدأت الحكومة الفيدرالية في
دعم الاختبارات وإنشاء
أنواع مختلفة من الاختبارات لأنواع مختلفة
من المواقف
واستخدام جوانب الإنتاج
لقدراتها للحصول على المزيد  من هذه المواد
المتاحة للناس
لأن شراء الاختبار الذي يبلغ 150 مليونًا يبدو
مثيرًا للإعجاب
فقط للمبتدئين ، فهذه قطرة
في الدلو ستستمر
لمدة أسبوع لمجتمعات في ورطة ،
نعم
كريس ، أنت تعرف ما أود رؤيته
وأنا  ستدفع من أجل هذا الأمر بشدة
بالإضافة إلى
الاختبارات القياسية شديدة الحساسية
التي تقوم بها إذا كنت تريد أن تعرف أن
هذا الشخص مصاب ، فأنت تريد إجراء
تتبع جهة اتصال عزل تحديد الهوية ، وهذا أمر جيد ،
لكن الشيء الذي سأدفعه
لشيء يعد اختبارًا منزليًا وهو
نقطة اهتمام
يمكنك إجراؤها بنفسك ، نعم لأنه إذا كان
بإمكانك القيام بذلك ،
فيمكنك الحصول على موقف
يعرف فيه شخص ما ما إذا كان  إذا كانوا مصابين
أو ما إذا كانت الأسرة التي
يحضرونها لتناول العشاء مصابة ، فهذا ليس هو
ما وافقت عليه إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير للتو نقطة رعاية
صحيحة تمامًا ولكنك تحتاج إلى الكثير
من هذا الشيء وهذا مجرد
الخطوة الأولى
التي تريدها  لكي أكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك ، يتطلب
الأمر وصفة طبية ، أود أن أرى واحدة حيث
لا تحتاج حتى إلى وصفة طبية.
قل أن
هذا شيء تحتاجه حقًا
نحتاج إلى أن نكون قادرين على
التعامل مع الأشخاص
المصابين والذين لم يصابوا واسمحوا
لي أن أخبركم لماذا كريس
لأن ما نراه الآن في
جميع أنحاء البلاد هو
التجمعات الأبرياء للعائلة
و  أصدقاء
في منزل حيث يتخلى الناس عن حذرهم
لأنهم أشخاص لديهم
أشخاص على دراية بهم بدأنا نرى
هذه الأنواع من العدوى ثمانية عشرة
أشخاص يجتمعون معًا
في مأدبة عشاء مع الأصدقاء والعائلة
واحد منهم
مصاب ولكن واي  لا توجد أعراض
يضعون حذرهم في الأسفل ، فأنت جالس
وأنت تأكل وأنت تشرب
، تخلع قناعك وهكذا بدأنا نشهد
عدوى أتصل بها على الهاتف
الليلة وأتحدث إلى جميع زملائي في
جميع أنحاء  البلد تقريبًا يقول كل واحد
منهم
أن هذا أصبح مصدرًا مهمًا جدًا
للعدوى ،
إذا كان لديك
اختبار يمكنك إجراؤه في المنزل بنفسك ،
نقطة رعاية
حساسة ومحددة ، يمكنك
القضاء على الكثير من ذلك ولكن هذا لا '
هذا هو نوع الاختبار
الذي أؤيده ولا يبدو أنه تفكير جديد ،
أشعر أن هذا كان واضحًا لفترة
طويلة ، فلماذا لا نمتلكه ،
نعم هذه هي النقطة ، دعونا نتوقف
عن التفكير في الأمر ، دعنا  فقط افعل ذلك ،
أعني أنك تسألني عما أريد
أن أفعله بشكل
صحيح ، أود أن أفعل ذلك الآن ، أود أن
أفعل ذلك بعد شهر من الآن بعد عام من الآن
عندما تتوقع أن يتم تطعيم أول شخص
حسنًا ، خطتنا هي أن نكون قادرين على
شحن اللقاحات إلى جهاز المناعة  مواقع ation
خلال 24 ساعة من الموافقة
لذلك أتوقع ربما في اليوم الثاني بعد
الموافقة
في 11 أو 12 ديسمبر
آمل أن يتم تحصين أول شخص
في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة في جميع الولايات
أه في جميع المناطق التي توجد فيها هذه الولاية
ستخبرنا الأقسام التي تم عقدها عن
مكان تقديم اللقاحات
وقلت إنك تخطط لتطعيم
20 مليون شخص في شهر
ديسمبر في الولايات المتحدة وما يصل إلى
30 مليونًا آخر شهريًا بعد ذلك كم عدد
الأمريكيين الذين يحتاجون إلى
التطعيم  الحياة لتكون قادرة على العودة إلى
طبيعتها ومتى يمكن أن يحدث
ذلك بشكل طبيعي مع مستوى الفعالية
لدينا
95٪ 70٪
أو نحو ذلك من السكان الذين يتم تحصينهم
سيسمح
لمناعة قطيع حقيقية أن تحدث والتي من
المحتمل أن تحدث
في مكان ما في  شهر مايو أو
شيء من هذا القبيل بناءً على
خططنا ، آمل حقًا وأتطلع إلى رؤية
أن مستوى الإدراك السلبي
للقاح
ينخفض وأن الناس  زيادة القبول
التي ستكون
ضرورية لمساعدتنا معظم الناس بحاجة
إلى التحصين قبل أن نتمكن من العودة
إلى الحياة الطبيعية ، أريد أن أصل إلى ذلك
في ثانية ولكن قبل أن نتحدث
عن حاجة الجمهور لفهم
أن هذا هو
لقد تحركت هذه اللقاحات المأمونة
بسرعة أكبر بكثير من
تطوير اللقاحات الحديثة والموافقة
عليها ، وهي عملية تستغرق عادةً
سنوات وسيتم إنجازها في غضون 10 أشهر فقط ، ما
مدى ثقتك في أنه
لن يكون هناك أي
آثار جانبية ضارة كبيرة مع
هذه اللقاحات.  من الطمأنينة ،
هل يمكنك تقديم
نعم ، لذا فإن الطريقة التي سارعنا بها هي
الاستفادة أولاً من
10 سنوات على الأقل من
البحث
حول ما يسمى تقنيات النظام الأساسي
التي تشبه تقريبًا
مشغل كاسيت حيث يمكنك
تركيب شرائط مختلفة
لموسيقى مختلفة ستكون شرائط مختلفة
لقاحات مختلفة
في هذه الحالة ، لقاح kovid 19 ، لذلك
فإن كل الجزء الأولي من الاكتشاف الذي
عادة ما يستغرق f  تم إجراء ستة أعوام
في شهرين حرفيًا ،
ثم نجري
تجارب سريرية أكبر بكثير مما
تتطلبه إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
للحصول على الموافقة ، لذا فإن مستوى
فهمنا على أساس عريض
من السكان للسلامة قصيرة المدى
للقاحات
هو في الواقع أفضل بكثير  أكثر مما
نفتقر إليه عادة
هو الأمان طويل المدى
فقط لأنها حقيقة
لا يمكننا متابعتها لفترة طويلة بشأن هذه
اللقاحات بينما
يموت من ألف إلى ألفي شخص كل يوم
وهذا هو الخطر الذي نعرفه
الآن وهو أمر مهم للغاية.  أشياء واحدة
أوضحت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) أنه بالنسبة لمئات
الآلاف من الأفراد الذين
شاركوا في التجارب السريرية
للقاح على مدار الأربعين عامًا الماضية ، فإن
90 إلى 95 في المائة من جميع الأحداث الضائرة الخطيرة
تحدث في غضون 40 يومًا من إكمال
التحصين ، وهذا هو السبب الذي جعل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
تقول
إننا بحاجة  بعد 60 يومًا من الانتهاء
من التحصين ، خضعت لمراقبة السلامة
قبل أن تتمكن من التقديم ، نعلم
أنه بالنسبة للقاحات ، فإننا نقدم
شركة فايزر
واللقاح الحديث
لا توجد أحداث سلبية خطيرة في
تلك الفترة الزمنية
بعد أن بدأنا في تحصين
السكان ، يقوم
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض وإدارة الغذاء والدواء (FDA) بإنشاء نظام
شامل للغاية ونشط لمراقبة اليقظة الدوائية
لتقييم وتوثيق سلامة
اللقاح ، أتوقع أن هذا اللقاح سوف
كن آمنًا مثل جميع اللقاحات الأخرى
التي يتم استخدامها في السكان
، وأود أن أحث الناس حقًا على الاستماع
إلى الخبراء ،
وإلقاء نظرة على البيانات ، والحفاظ على أذهانهم منفتحة
،
ونأمل أن تقبل التحصين ،
إنها حقيقة لم يرها هذا الجزء من تكساس
إلا
في كوابيسها ، تعمل وحدة
العناية المركزة في المركز الطبي الإقليمي في أوديسا في أوديسا بولاية تكساس
على استيعاب 19
مريضًا
حتى مع وجود هذا المستشفى بأقصى
طاقته وما زالوا يحاولون العثور على
أماكن
لوضع مرضى كوفيد 19 جميع الأسرة
التي تراها
في هذا  القسم الذي تم حجبه في
الوقت الحالي لم يكن موجودًا
قبل الجائحة الآن ، فهو
ممتلئ بقدرته المطلقة بينما المرضى
هنا
حرفياً الشكل  نبش بحياتهم ،
فقدنا حوالي
10 مرضى الأسبوع الماضي وكان أحدهم
في مرشد هنا لمدة
شهر تقريبًا
، أولئك الموجودون هنا الآن في المتوسط
وا في الحدث لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا أو
ا شا
ه ذلك.  اقتربنا جيدًا
من ممارس ممرضة رعاية حادة
لم يكن هناك سوى بضع مرات في الصيف
حيث تم دفعنا حقًا
إلى أقصى الحدود ولكننا الآن خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
نتخلص من اللحامات لكنها ظلت هي
وكل شخص آخر
في حالة حرب معها  الفيروس حتى عندما
يبدأ بعض المرضى في اتخاذ منعطف نحو الأسوأ عندما يتعين
عليك أولاً تقديم
هذا الإعلان ، ما هو أول
شيء يدور في ذهنك ، من
فضلك لا تفعل شيئًا آخر تعرفه ،
إنها صلاة لا مفر منها
ونعرف ما الذي يحدث  أن يحدث لكن
احتمال أن تكون نتيجة جيدة
منخفض جدًا ولكن معظمهم قادرون على محاربته
انظر إليك واستدر روبن
روميرو يشعر بتحسن
بعد أسبوعين في المستشفى ويقول إن
هذه ليست لعبة
أنا  سأل ث  مرحباً
لأن هذا أمر خطير حقًا ، يقول إن
هذا الفيروس ليس
للأشخاص الذين يلعبون به ، إنه أمر خطير للغاية ،
إنه يهاجم جسمك بالكامل
أنا أعيشه ، كما يقول ، وقد أصبحت حياة
للكثيرين في هذا الجزء من
مسؤولي مستشفى الولاية في أوديسا  لنفترض أن
ما بين 35 إلى
40 في المائة من الأشخاص الذين يخضعون للاختبار أثبتت
إصابتهم بالفيروس 19. إنهم يخشون أن يصبحوا ما أصبح
الباسو
مشارحًا متنقلة
للمئات القتلى في وحدة العناية المركزة وسط
دخول المستشفى
بشكل قياسي وحوالي شخص واحد من كل 24 شخصًا
مصابًا بفيروس كورونا.  تطلبت
تنسيقًا إقليميًا
لم يسبق له مثيل في فترة زمنية قصيرة نسبيًا
، أضافت مستشفياتنا أكثر من 600 سرير
حتى بعد أن نقلنا حوالي
84 مريضًا بوحدة العناية المركزة إلى مجتمعات أخرى في
تكساس
والمدن الأصغر التي كان يُعتقد أنها
نجت من قبضة الفيروس.
في البلدات المتقاطعة
مثل lamesa texas بالقرب من أوديسا ، تم إدخال بارون إلى
المستشفى مرتين
مع الطمع 19. التشخيص تسمع
أكثر و  أكثر
في مجتمعها ، الكلمة المخيفة هي
إيجابية ، أنا متأكد من
أني كنت أتحقق من النتيجة الإيجابية ، لقد حصلنا على اثنين
آخرين في الوقت الحالي ، لقد عانينا من الموت
في كنيستنا بالأمس ، هذه الأشياء
حقيقية ،
إنها مستشفى الفنون الطبية المخيفة حيث
عولجت في الغالب
الآن  جناح كامل مخصص
لتحولات 19 مريضًا
أصبحت تجارب مشتركة ،
فنحن في الواقع نرسل المرضى إلى المنزل على
الأكسجين المنزلي
للتعافي في المنزل ، وهذا ليس شيئًا
نفعله في العادة ولكن لا يوجد
مكان
طوال فترة القتال التي استمرت لأشهر دون أن يكون
واضحًا
علامات على نهاية الناس لا يتخذون
الاحتياطات التي يحتاجون إليها ،
نعم نحن في الخطوط الأمامية هنا في
المستشفى ولكن الخط الأمامي
الحقيقي في الشوارع في متاجر البقالة ،
اغسل يديك وارتدي حصيرك ابق بعيدًا ،
وأعدك بأن القليل  القليل من الوقت
والقليل من الجهد الذي يتطلبه الأمر
خارج
هنا يستحق كل هذا العناء لأنه بمجرد أن
ترتدي قناعًا أفضل من وضع
أنبوب أسفل حلقك ،
أعدك